foreign
[Music]
City
air usually has their head in the clouds
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy
nothing weird going on here uh just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
[Music]
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
[Music]
the pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
plus my dad would boil you alive why
does anyone get to tell you what you can
do in your life come on
why do they even have these yes who
knows
remember I see a change in you
what hair guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes
never once asked what I wanted to do
write this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
foreign
[Music]
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
um